absolutely anyways I want to hang stone
yes Stone movie came in from netflix I'm
not expecting too much out of me because
nobody really seemed to like it very
much but I thought it looked really good
and i love the cast but he came nowhere
so if i don't look good too but I got it
it's like split 50-50 on rotten tomatoes
and you know I just surprised that they
got absolutely no release I know it's
weird he got nowhere by the way did you
see Robert De Niro's acceptance speech
on the golden globes for the cecil b
demille award yeah he mentioned stone
unlike movies that people don't really
like i love that i was like he doesn't
give a crap when people think he's just
saying whatever he wants i was like
that's awesome like he's like like you
would like to see a little more
everybody's fine and a little more a
stone in that goodbye and see what do
that that's like that's awesome thank
you for saying that cuz it's I don't
like when people do that it's true like
they they just generalize all the big
ones like bullet okay or show Raging
Bull obviously it will show Goodfellas
they didn't show he that took me off I
don't they sure one shot from heat okay
they showed one shot for me the parents
and one shot from heat and I was like
okay because I mean he gave a really
stinking good performance in both of
those movies especially in heat and and
meet the parents I mean I know it was a
comedic performance but he was really
good in that movie and that was one of
the first movies I think he made analyze
that first and then or analyze this or
whatever one came first that was like
his first big comedy and then he made
meet the parents but in the 80s he made
that one movie The King of Comedy with
Martin Scorsese which I loved but you
know that's all my netflix queue us to
see that i love that movie that was
that's one of my favorites for Sadie
movies actually but um anyway like and I
hope I was annoyed too and when the
nearest said that I'm saying it's
awesome thank you one on which movie I'm
sorry he said they didn't say anything
about stone or everybody's fine or any
of us for Stanley and iris or any of it
they're left unknown film she said he
said like Marvins room or whatever room
yet yeah but I thought your time by the
specific movie that he mentioned that
you like oh I I love everybody's fine Oh
everybody's fine that's what you're
talking about yeah that was okay for me
actually made me cry it was it was
interesting I'd slighted yeah I speak
you Chris it did speak to me it that'll
be pani do some integer because okay my
grandpa is like the exact same as him
the movie opens is his wife just died my
grandpa's my grandma died recently and
it just shows him like doing his daily
chores trying to take care of the house
doing all the stuff that she used to do
same thing as my grandpa then he decides
to go on a road trip to like recapture
his family life and stuff and it's like
very similar to my grandpa and then
stuff happened layer the movie and I was
like practice yeah but it was really
good mm-hmm I thought the narrow you
really good in it yeah he was really
good he's like oh no he seemed to be
really good in everything for the most
part like yeah I'm what I say that I'm
speaking of movies that aren't very good
overall compared to his first words
right what I don't know I think I'm
talking about this or but I really do
not like the remake of cape fear at all
i think it's really silly yeah but he's
really really good at it yeah yes for
not i guess like a little bit we've
we've talked about this before like that
was exaggerated death scene it like
movie straight she's drowning it like a
little bit older kid who got all the
king robert loggia chrysler move it's
like possessed or something i don't know
but um yeah about yeah what you were
saying every time i see a movie with him
I can almost guarantee that I'll like
him even if I don't like the movie
even little fockers yeah I liked him in
that movie I mean I mean I can tell that
he didn't really enjoy the writing or
whatever they were given that much but I
thought I'll did I really Chris really
yeah okay did you see him at when he
accepted his uh his Cecil B deMille
Award he's like I'm glad I'm glad they
chose me give me this a war before the
reviews for little fockers came in like
that's awesome he's just probably de
made himself that's awesome it's hard to
like it with that movie is that early
like a crummy about character is yeah
it's probably good i love the first one
so much yeah it's kind of just like I
when I was just such lazy writing for
that movie there's actually no setup for
anything that goes on yeah it's just a
way to to get him and Stiller and odds
with each other again yeah but it's like
everything that happens that would be
like does not have a proper setup my is
Owen Wilson even in the movie because
yes Owen Wilson because it's Owen Wilson
why does a giant thing of white know why
does um uh ben stiller's character
attempt to like drive that towing thing
of sand so they can have that hilarious
sequence where they accidentally dumped
it on Robert De Niro I have and why does
Jessica Alba drink I mean a swallow
erectile dysfunction medication so they
can have an excuse to shore in her
lingerie yeah that's actually you might
as well just go as far as saying why is
jessica alba in movies so they can have
any excuse to show her face or her bike
shut up she's a fantastic actress and
I'm not agreeing with you there she's
not a worse oh not at all I'm just
thinking really hard right now to see if
I've seen her good performance exactly I
have never once seen Jessica Alba give a
performance where I was like wow well in
her slight defense has she been in an
acting a movie like my point exactly in
fact I didn't see the killer inside me
with casey affleck maybe she's good
enough every movie that she's in man
it's like she cannot have a scene
even where she she can't she asked I was
seen semi unclothed there's something I
mean with a funny thing is that she
never does nudity either cuz it's like
she has like this big old thing against
I like Natalie Portman yeah but she's
like known for her sexiness I mean the
thing is she's in movies where you think
there'd be acting like the eye or
whatever which where she's blind and she
sees did you see that movie yes I did
actually I was dumb but I mean all of
her performances I'm just unremarkable
don't even oh there is invisible girl
sorry I forgot about the link I just
sent you is a picture that really
captures Jessica I was beauty okay is
there a picture for opening a stove and
screaming into the stove it's from the I
girl it is remember that scene that's
funny why are you screaming at a stove I
don't know there's some sort of the side
of that bloody stove okay there's a um
this this will lead into some sort of
interesting discussion there's an ad for
just go with it on the right side of my
screen currently doesn't that look like
a masterpiece totally I'm gonna really
go out on a limb here it's a very
ambitious thing I'm about to say but I'm
going to guess just maybe the adam
sandler jennifer aniston will end up
together it's impossible easy beautiful
far cry but I have a feeling it's a
possibility you know you can stick and
see out come to every movie in the
trailers there is a lot of sleep no
other way that the movie had edged Chris
the tears what's going to happen Oh
Jennifer Aniston she's all nerdy looking
she's not attractive even though she
still is I'll understand how she could
be beautiful anyway oh look i'm gonna
try to you know get with this hot girl
oh crap i need to pretend i have a wife
I'll get my nerdy not good-looking
friend too
for me oh crap she dressed up and she
looks hot now dude um he's gonna like
slowly start to see like how immature
like the young girl is of course like
how snobby she is and then he's gonna
like see how great of a mother jande for
Aniston is to the kids and they're gonna
faking being a father with with her kids
and so he's gonna like realize he wants
to be their stepfather it's gonna be
amazing and at the end I guarantee
you'll have some huge realization and
have to like chase her to like wherever
she is because she may be leaving
somewhere forever on a plane or
something right though there has to be
that Airport see ya and he's gonna
probably see running through the airport
as fast as you can or take a taxi follow
that car or something and display I hate
how you can see these movies like I love
havin I i can say that i love adam
sandler Vadhu is he afraid to like be in
a movie that is not directed by David
Dugan like look in his filmography it
was last year whenever this mission yeah
this year he's in to Dennis Dugan movies
and who's the Segal guy Segal yeah he
said he's with a director I think it's
jason jason segel no i don't know he
after is a director no it's a director I
think it's peter segal or something Oh
directs him a lot yeah um yeah that is a
director I slipped it up yeah he
directed gay longest yard 50 first dates
anger management yeah that seems to be
all though so he's like the nether Adam
Sandler I see Adam Sandler what he's
doing is he'll make like to really
stupid movies and then all of a sudden
make a good one like he made punch-drunk
love then he made some rather other
random movies he made Spanglish some
other random movies then he made funny
people like he's I didn't see funny
people I really like floating people
that's a great movie and I thought
Spanglish was alright but when I watched
it again
k Leone's character are much have you
sprained over me yes I like that too
he's great in that movie should have got
an Oscar nomination he's very good and I
like what he does serious roles more
than it when he does his sophomore
economy but I mean I like that too just
because I grew up with like happy
gilmore and stuff so when I see so it
was you know dumb comedy movies it's
entertaining to watch but yeah I I just
the other thing is like there's a family
of that I principe there's two young
teenage girls and they love to go to
those kind of movies and the sad thing
is they love all of them I mean they
love all the really stupid romantic
comedies but they didn't really like 500
days of summer that much because it was
different I mean like I could totally
tell you exactly what's gonna happen in
this movie before it starts like it I
know but we don't care it's really
annoying like next movie I go with them
I'm actually gonna do that oh yeah
that's the yeah that's the people you've
told me about before yeah the next time
I go to movie with you I'm gonna do that
I'm going to tell them exactly how it's
going to play out if it's one of those
type of movies and just see what happens
so they can they can realize how
predictable their favorite movie though
something is suddenly happening with
your audio it sounds like you're
underwater oh really hopefully it
doesn't select oh you actually just got
better that happens sometimes I don't
know why maybe it's cuz you're stupid
yeah that's probably it Blake okay cool
alright well what what well go so we
should tell people about green zone
since we both since he liked it yes me
and Chris have the very strong belief
that green zone of 2010 starring matt
damon and directed by whoever whatever
his name is i don't know i was an
underrated film I know uh all green
grass I just got a text Rima grass yeah
paul greengrass oh i thought it might
have been the other poor guy okay cool I
just got a text from somebody that's
hilarious sorry okay
yeah anyway jugador de read it out loud
crisp no I reply real quick oh my god
haha im stearing podcast that's what I'm
writing there's no funny stuff okay
would okay yeah so anyway I don't
understand how anyone could not like
green zone I mean I watched it I heard
people say it was born that movie is
non-stop action like I don't mean just
you know action action there's Larry all
the dialogue is action everyone's always
walking somewhere vastly to get
something it's like it never stops then
the last half an hour was like I was on
the edge of my bed cuz I watched it when
I was on my bed that should be a quote
like on the box but yeah this may be an
edge of an edge of the bed thrill ride
this movies and nail-biting edge of the
better I was on the edge of my bed the
entire bill yeah it's a great movie i
don't understand the disliking i don't
really get it maybe it's just because it
has come out in a film or we have had
very many similar stories but that
doesn't really change how you view the
quality when you see the film I guess I
can understand that in terms of lack of
box-office success but I don't get why
people say it's a bad movie after seeing
it I think the reason people don't like
it is because it has political opinions
and stuff and generally like I think of
a viewer does not share the same
political viewpoint of the film they
just won't like it
you have your think of that yeah it's
another thing because I mean one of the
things Roger Ebert said was that it was
one of the first american war movies to
ever make us look dumb because usually
american war movies like yeah american
pride yeah la la this one was the mic
one of the first ones that was like yeah
we kind of messed up because it's about
weapons of mass destruction and looking
for them and as we know we never found
any so it makes us look retarded and so
I don't know people might not like that